THE 2018 MIDTERM THEY DEMONIZE
THE NRA.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
LAST NIGHT AT A CNN TOWN HALL,
MARCO RUBIO WALKED INTO THE
LION'S DEN WITH A FILLET MINGNON
IN HIS TRAFFIC.
>> IT'S HARD TO LOOK AT NOW AND
NOT LOOK DOWN THE BARREL OF AN
AR-15 CAN YOU TELL ME YOU WILL
NOT ACCEPT A DINGAL -- SINGLE
DONATION FROM THE NRA IN THE
FUTURE
>> Laura: RUBO WAS GUTSY TO SHOW
UP AND HEAR THE KIDS OUT BUT
WASN'T FUN AND QUICKLY BECAME A
PUNCHING BAG FOR THE CROWD AND
QUESTIONERS A COMPLETE LACK OF
RESPECT BE
RESPECT B
RESPECT FR
RESPECT FROM
RESPECT FROM T
RESPECT FROM TEE
RESPECT FROM TEENA
RESPECT FROM TEENAGE
RESPECT FROM TEENAGERS
RESPECT FROM TEENAGERS A
RESPECT FROM TEENAGERS AND
ADULTS IN THE ROOM.
>> THINK OF HOW FAR YOU CAN DO
AS A RESULT OF VOICING YOUR
BELIEF.
YOU CAN SHOUT ME DOWN WHEN I'M
FINISHED BUT AS OTHER MEDIA
NETWORKS WOULD HAVE COVERED IT.
WAIT A SECOND -- HE SHOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PURCHASE THE
FIREARM.
>> Laura: NATURELY THE MEDIA LAP
UP THE NASTINESS AND THERE WAS
ZERO CRITICISM OF THE HECKLERS
WHO SHOWED ZERO EXPECT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO SHOWED UP FOR REAL
DIALOGUE.
MAYBE GET SOMETHING
ACCOMPLISHED.
INSTEAD THE PEOPLE ON THE STAGE
WALKED INTO A CIRCUS.
IMAGINE IF CONSERVATIVE STUDENTS
WOULD HAVE SCREAMED AT SENATOR
BILL NELSON WHEN HE MADE THIS
POINT.
>> DID YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE GAVE INCENTIVES FOR THE
COLT CORPORATION TO COME TO
KISSIMMEE TO MANUFACTURE AR-15s.
THE SAME ONE THAT WREAKED SUCH
HAVOC.
>> Laura: OKAY.
WELL WHAT NELSON CONVENIENTLY
LEFT OUT IS DESPITE THE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES THEY NEVER
MOVED THEIR FACTORY TO FLORIDA
AND THINK ABOUT THIS, WHAT IS SO
HORRIBLE ABOUT ENCOURAGING
MANUFACTURERS OF LEGAL PRODUCTS
CREATE JOBS?
SO IS THE GOVERNOR, FOR
INSTANCE, OFFERED TAX BREAKS TO
A DISTILLERY RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVERY DRUNK ACCIDENT.
THE A.P., THE WASHINGTON POST
AND OTHERS CREATED CARDGATE.
YES, PRESIDENT TRUMP HELD A
CARD.
>> THERE WAS A LOT MADE OF THE
NOTE OUTLINING THE STEPS OF
EMPATHY.
>> AS IF THE PRESIDENT HAD TO BE
REMINDED TO SYMPATHIZE.
>> THERE WAS A PHOTO OF THE NOTE
HE HAD BROUGHT TO SPEAK TO THE
FAMILIES.
>> THIS IS HOW DESPERATE THE
PRESS IS.
THE PRESIDENT HOLD AN
UNPRECEDENTED CONFERENCE WITH
TEACHERS AND STUDENTS AND
SURVIVORS AND SOMETHING THEY
WOULD HAVE BEGGED PRESIDENT
OBAMA FOR AND I SHOULD HAVE
HOPED THE PRESIDENT WOULD HAVE
WALKED INTO AN EVENT LIKE THIS,
VERY PREPARED.
IF THEY HAD NO NOTES THEY'D SAY
HE JUST WINGED IT AND DOESN'T
CARE ABOUT THE KIDS.
THE ANTI-GUN ACTIVISTS HAVE
EVERY RIGHT TO PITCH TO BAN
WEAPONS BUT THEY'RE NOT FLIGHTED
TO THEIR OWN FACTS.
THEY ROUTINELY CLAIM, FOR
INSTANCE, THE NRA IS AGAINST
BACKGROUND CHECKS.
IT HIT IS WAYNE LA PIERRE AT
CPAC.
>> THEY ORIGINATED THE CHECK
SYSTEM.
IT WAS OUR BILL.
NO ONE ON THE PROHIBITED
PERSON'S LIST SHOULD EVER HAVE
ACCESS TO A FIREARM.
NO KILLER, NO FELON, NO DRUG
DEALER.
>> MY FRIEND JAKE TAPPER DIDN'T
FOCUS ON THAT THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED HIS SUPPORT SAYING THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK HARD AT THE NRA
ARE GREAT PATRIOTS AND LOVE OUR
COUNTRY AND WILL DO THE RIGHT
THING.
WELL, THIS SEND THE LOW-BROW
LEFTIES INTO PAROXISMS OF
OUTRAGE BECAUSE THEY WANT OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE TO THINK OF THE NRA
AS A REPREHENSIBLE BLOOD-THIRSTY
ORGANIZATION WHO IN THE WORDS OF
ONE KILLED ON CNN, TERRORISTS.
>> THE TALKED ABOUT EMOTIONS --
>> THE NRA BOUGHT POLITICIANS TO
SAY THAT.
>> Laura: AGAIN, I CANNOT STRESS
THIS ENOUGH, THE DEMOCRATS AND
THEIR LEFTIST ENABLERS ARE
DESPERATE TO DISTRACT YOU FROM
ALL THE GOOD NEWS THAT'S
HAPPENING AROUND US THINK ABOUT
THIS A NEW POLL OUT TELLS US 45%
OF AMERICANS ARE SATISFIED WITH
OUR STANDING IN THE WORLD.
THAT'S A 13-YEAR HIGH AND 13
PERCENTAGE POINT INCREASE FROM
JUST A YEAR AGO.
SMALL BUSINESS CONFIDENCE IS WAY
UP, THE ECONOMY IS STRONG, AND
SO ALL THE DEMOCRATS CAN DO IN
RESPONSE IS TO CREATE NEW
BOOGEYMAN.
NOW IT'S THE NRA.
FOR A YEAR, THEY'VE TRIED TO
PEDDLE CONTEMPT FOR PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP AND TODAY HIS
APPROVAL NUMBERS ARE HIGHER THAN
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED.
THE GENERIC REPUBLICAN AGAINST
DEMOCRAT BALLOT TIGHTENING.
SOME HAVE THE GOP NOW WITHIN
THREE POINTS OF THE DEMOCRAT.
THE DEMOCRATS LED BY DOUBLE
DIGITS TWO MONTHS AGO.
SURE, THE COUNTRY STILL HAS
PROBLEM, DRUG ADDICTION AND
VIOLENCE IN BALTIMORE AND THE
SPREAD OF MS-13 AND NOW WE KNOW
THE NEED TO IMPROVE THE SCHOOL
SAFETY BUT GENERALLY THINGS ARE
GETTING BETTER.
THEY'RE GETTING BETTER FOR MORE
PERSONS AND THIS IS DRIVING
DEMOCRATS ABSOLUTELY BONKERS.
SO MUCH SO THEY'RE WILLING TO
EXPLOIT THE PAIN OF THE YOUNG
DOUGLAS STONE SURVIVORS.
I'D LIKE TO SAY I'M SURPRISED
BUT I'M NOT.
MANY ON THE LEFT HAVE BEEN DOING
THIS DOING THIS KIND OF THING
FOR DECADES.
AND THEY'VE TRIED TO CONVINCE
THE PEOPLE, THE CITIZENS TO
SACRIFICE THEIR INDIVIDUAL
RIGHTS, THEY'RE BASIC FREEDOMS
FOR THE COMMON GOOD.
A FEW MORE TAXES HERE, A FEW
MORE REGULATIONS THERE, AND NOW
THEY WANT TO WATER DOWN THE
SECOND AMENDMENT ON THE FALSE
PROMISE TO DO SO WILL BE AN END
TO ALL THE SCHOOL KILLINGS.
WE WON'T HAVE SCHOOL KILLINGS
ANYMORE BUT I SAY WE SHOULD BE
VERY CAREFUL HERE.
ADMINISTRATIVE STATE WANTS TO
TAKE AWAY GUNS USING TRAGEDIES
AS EXCUSES BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT THE PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL TO
HAVE PERSONAL POWER.
AS BEN FRANKLIN ONCE WROTE,
THOSE WHO WOULD GIVE US A SENSE